c'est bien le siège est vraiment chaud
en fait bonjour Christophe
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires on est ensemble
pendant un peu plus de 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale bonjour Julien Lecuyer
bonjour de la voiture
on a beaucoup changé à voir avec vous
Christophe Béchu on commence par la
politique migratoire liée au
réchauffement climatique justement
puisque les migrations liées au
réchauffement climatique vont se
multiplier on a vu par exemple ces
derniers jours des inondations qui ont
touché le Niger le Tchad les pays
voisins qui ont déplacé 1,4 millions de
personnes une étude dit que le
changement climatique a rendu 80 fois
plus probable c'est forte pluie ça veut
dire qu'il y aura de plus en plus de
réfugiés qui tonton venir en Europe
est-ce que l'accueil de ces réfugiés
peut rester exceptionnel comme le dit le
gouvernement de plusieurs jours
d'abord il faut insister que ces
migrations ne sont pas des migrations du
Sud vers le Nord il y a aussi des
migrations entre pays du Sud il y a eu
des dizaines de millions de personnes
déplacées au Pakistan par des
inondations sont pas des gens qui sont
venus en Europe donc il faut pas
généraliser non plus des chiffres qu'on
voit parfois dans la presse et qui sont
agités à certains à certains dessins
accueillir des gens qui sont dans une
situation de détresse comme ce qui s'est
passé avec deux chiens Vikings dans une
situation particulière c'est
exceptionnel parce que on s'est subroger
à la situation italienne c'est ce qui
nous a amené à tenir ses propos et à
expliquer qu'il y avait à la fois un
devoir d'humanité parce qu'on n'allait
pas laisser des gens se noyer mais que
dans le même temps ça voulait pas dire
qu'il fallait qu'on crée une sorte
d'appel d'air d'une façon quelconque
avec la France doit garder une maîtrise
de sa politique migratoire c'est la
raison pour laquelle certains textes
vont être proposés le vrai sujet compte
tenu de ce réchauffement climatique
c'est comment on aide les pays à y faire
face comment d'abord on accentue nos
efforts pour éviter que ce dérèglement
continue à s'emballer et ensuite comme
on les aide à s'adapter au coeur de la
cop27 il y a un sujet qui est pas
forcément de plus médiatique parce que
on parle pas de degré on parle d'euros
on parle de milliards de dollars sur la
façon dont les pays du Nord doivent
constituer des fonds pour être capable
d'accompagner à la fois l'adaptation et
l'atténuation au changement climatique
dans les pays du Sud mais en direction
c'est une des directions prises par
Emmanuel Macron qui souhaite associer
plus profondément les pays les pays
africains notamment qui vont être
victimes du réchauffement climatique
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut aller
bien plus loin dans cette relation
bilatérale
Emmanuel Macron c'est à la fois battu
pour que les 100 milliards qui ont été
promis par le passé soit atteint je vous
rappelle que sur ces 100 milliards
d'euros promis par les pays riches la
France en apporte 6 ce qui est tout à
fait ça part compte tenu de la Somme le
sujet c'était n'importe quoi ils sont
pas atteints c'est 100 milliards 83
milliards avec les États-Unis qui
payaient pas le déplacement du président
Biden c'était pour dire qu'il allait
acquitter la part des États-Unis on
espère évidemment qu'ils vont le faire
il y a un petit sujet avec l'Australie
avec quelques pays qui doivent finir de
payer la déclaration finale hier du G20
par le Président de la République dans
ce sens c'est à la fois l'effectivité
des 100 milliards et c'est un message
très fort pour proposer que l'Union
africaine participe au G20 et que
précisément y compris dans des lieux
dont des instances de décision on se
retrouve pas à prendre des décisions
pour la planète sans impliquer un
continent qui malheureusement est en
première ligne sur ces sujets
climatiques comme je l'évoquez et qui
est aussi une partie de la solution pas
que du problème dans la manière dont on
voit les choses il y a en particulier
des réserves de biodiversité
exceptionnelle en Afrique nous ferons à
libre à la fin du premier trimestre un
sommet mondial consacré à l'avenir de la
forêt parce que un des sujets c'est
comment est-ce qu'on aide ces pays à ne
pas avoir envie d'accentuer ou de
déforester des sites comme le bassin du
Congo mais au contraire à s'engager dans
des programmes comme la Grande muraille
verte c'est à dire dans des programmes
massifs de plantation d'arbres pour
capter du carbone et pour faire en sorte
de préserver une biodiversité qui est
essentielle à notre planète
ce sera donc co-organisé par la France
et par le Gabon ce sera un One Forrest
summith c'est-à-dire un sommet aura
vocation à s'adresser au monde entier et
à regarder comment sur ces sujets les
pays du Nord peuvent donner aussi un
coup de main au pays du Sud de manière
beaucoup plus forte pour les accompagner
dans la préservation de ces réservoirs
de biodiversité
dans le premier trimestre l'annonce elle
a été faite au début de de la COP mais
elle rejoint un autre sujet d'un mot
parce qu'on est vraiment sur ces sur ces
enjeux environnementaux ils sont
cruciaux dans quelques heures quelques
jours va se finir la cop27 à Charmed
cher mais dans quelques jours aussi
comment une nouvelle Cope la COP 15 à
Montréal qui elle est totalement centrée
sur les enjeux de biodiversité et la
position que j'irai défendre là-bas
c'est la préservation dans tous les pays
du monde de 30% des terres et 30% des
mers pour qu'on ait des sanctuaires à la
fois de biodiversité de préservation des
écosystèmes à la minute je vous parle on
est presque 115 pays dans cette
coalition qu'on a lancé avec le Costa
Rica pour défendre cette position forte
et là aussi l'annonce en ouverture de la
COP 27 par le Président de la République
que nous opposerions à toute
exploitation des fonds sous-marins
nous permet de coaliser des pays sur la
préservation de ces de ces îlotes ces
sanctuaires dont on a absolument besoin
juste une petite question je la tue
parce que on sait que les milieux les
plus militants on voit ces coques comme
des sommets ou 12 sortes finalement pas
beaucoup de décisions et finalement pas
en tout cas à la mesure des enjeux
climatiques comment vous vous percevez
toutes les actions de ces de ces
militants comme d'Asperger les de
peinture les œuvres d'art ou de bloquer
les routes pour sensibiliser les
questions climatiques
je pense que ça dessert profondément la
cause que ça prétend servir
ça provoque l'incompréhension les gens
ne voient pas le lien et que c'est
actions aient lieu dans les seuls pays
au monde qui ont commencé à baisser leur
émission de gaz à effet de serre
provoque aussi chez une partie des gens
une forme de décalage il y a une
vingtaine de pays sur la planète
aujourd'hui qui ont baissé leurs
émissions alors pas au bon rythme ils
doivent faire en sorte d'accélérer
également mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à l'échelle du monde
l'Europe et le seul continent qui a
diminué qui a effectivement commencé à
diminuer ses émissions on n'est pas dans
le bon rythme il faut qu'on accélère
mais allez dire vous ne faites rien
c'est faux par les inactions climatiques
quand des quantités de gens déjà
commencé à changer leurs habitudes font
en sorte de prendre davantage le vélo on
modifié leur habitude de déplacement de
de consommation quand des décisions
courageuses sont prises comme la sortie
des véhicules thermiques quand on engage
des plans de rénovation peut-être qu'il
faut aller plus vite certainement même
juste et décalé c'est ça
contre-productif le vrai sujet c'est pas
que ce soit injuste mais c'est
contre-productif ce que ça provoque
c'est pas tiens l'écologie et une cause
à laquelle je vais me rallier c'est pas
ça que ça provoque un dernier mot
là-dessus puisque le groupe les
républicains l'Assemblée nationale
demande une mission d'information sur le
suivi des objectifs affichés par le
gouvernement en matière climatique et
notamment sur l'accord de Paris vous
êtes favorable je n'ai aucun problème
avec le fait qu'il y ait des missions
parlementaires qui soient conduites et
c'est pas un membre du gouvernement
d'apprécier s'il est souhaitable ou pas
que le Parlement travaille dans une
direction je n'ai aucun problème
je peux pas croire que les républicains
et le moindre doute sur la volonté
écologique du gouvernement parce qu'il
considérait qu'on en fait pas assez on
va parler de la question de l'eau c'est
à la haine de la Voix du Nord on va
regarder ça oui une grande préoccupation
de de la Voix du Nord mais également de
pas mal de départements puisque il y a
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux là qui
sont actuellement toujours soumis à des
restrictions sur les prélèvements et les
usages de l'eau vous évoquez même vous
avez évoqué récemment des restrictions
en potentiel encore en décembre ou
janvier est-ce qu'on va vers une
finalement une pénurie permanente qui
réclamera des restrictions sur
l'ensemble de l'année
le 29 juillet
et j'ai pris un décret qui permet toute
l'année toute l'année de pouvoir
potentiellement prendre des restrictions
on l'a pas fait parce qu'on savait pas
quoi faire le 29 juillet on l'a fait
parce que aujourd'hui on a une situation
de stress hydrique de qui est
inquiétante sur le territoire
l'été qu'on a vécu c'était le résultat
de 9 mois de déficit de pluviométrie la
situation dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui vous venez de le dire de
manière très juste c'est qu'on a encore
dans le pays des endroits qui sont sous
tension parce qu'on n'a pas eu
suffisamment d'eau et
les perspectives que nous avons alors
elles vont pas jusqu'à l'été prochain
mais elle nous conduisent à devoir
économiser l'eau et dans un réflexe de
fin de l'abondance de fin de
l'insouciance pour reprendre la Une de
votre journal ce matin et donc pour être
précis nous avons fin septembre à
Marseille avec Bérengère Couillard et
avec le ministère de l'agriculture avec
Marc féno lancé les assises de l'eau qui
sont à la fois un retour complet
d'expérience sur l'été qu'on a vécu et
sur les 12 derniers mois et qui sont un
panel d'actions que nous lançons 20% de
l'eau potable dans ce pays elle part
dans les fuites de canalisation et on a
des écarts qui vont de 5 6% pour les
réseaux les plus performants jusqu'à 70%
de fuite dans certaines communes
nous ne réutilisons les eaux usées
retraitées que à moins de 1% 10 fois
plus en Italie 20 fois plus en Espagne
80 fois plus en Israël d'habitude de se
dire de l'eau mais justement sur des
pistes sur lesquelles nous travaillons
justement les pistes c'est quoi c'est un
investissement massif dans la réparation
des canalisations on sait que c'est un
énorme déficit et qu'on ait largement en
retard par exemple par rapport à
l'Allemagne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire on peut
effectivement diviser par deux les taux
de fuites il y a plein de phénomènes et
de facteurs sur lesquels nous jouons
dans le cadre de ces assises de l'eau on
aura addition la fin de l'année un plan
d'action qui sera détaillé sur les
différents items il y a des sujets sur
lesquels on a commencé à travailler et
les autres ils feront l'objet
d'engagement précis diviser par deux le
taux de fuite c'est un excellent élément
la fin de l'année c'est la perspective
qu'on a donnée à l'ensemble de ceux qui
travaillent c'est-à-dire toutes les
agences de bassin le Conseil national de
l'eau des acteurs qui sont issus des
différents mondes des utilisateurs
est-ce que ça doit permettre aussi en
cause la stratégie de construction des
des bassines face à ce stress hydrique
donc vous parlez d'abord ça doit nous
conforter dans la lutte contre
l'étalement urbain parce qu'on risque de
vous surprendre la première nécessité
c'est qu'on puisse continuer à alimenter
les nappes phréatiques et plus vous
urbanisez plus bétonnez plus vous poser
cette difficulté ensuite sur les
bassines ou sur les retenus parce que
les mots ont un sens
en soi le procédé on peut pas le
qualifier de bons et de mauvais le vrai
sujet c'est que avant toute chose il
faut qu'on fasse évoluer nos et les
agriculteurs aussi c'est-à-dire d'aller
vers des pratiques qui sont moins
consommatrices en eau pour autant projet
par projet vous pouvez avoir des
endroits où ça a du sens de vous
retrouver avec une retenue qui vous
évite de pomper dans les tirages pendant
l'été parce que la plupart des
agriculteurs il n'accaparent pas l'eau
pour leur consommation personnelle il
utilise pour faire en sorte de produire
ce que nous mangeons et il y a une
certaine hypocrisie à taper sur
l'agriculture parce que si on a un recul
de notre agriculture et qu'on augmente
ce qu'on importe en termes d'agriculture
avec souvent des considérations
environnementales nettement moins
regardante que celle que nous avons
on ne résout pas le problème ils sont
hypocrites pour vous
deux choses je ne confonds pas un jeune
qui jette de la purée sur un tableau
avec quelqu'un qui jette une boule de
pétanque ou un cocktail Molotov sur un
gendarme et donc ce que je souhaite
aussi c'est qu'on soit capable de faire
la distinction et de ne pas donner le
nom d'écologie à des gens qui sous
couverts de pseudos revendications
écologistes font au contraire en sorte
de Charles
je le reprends pas je considère que on
l'espèce la cause c'est juste le
paravent qui permet un déferlement de
violence aucune cause ne justifie de
s'en prendre à l'intégrité physique d'un
agent des services publics
en ce moment à l'Assemblée nationale à
quel compromis êtes-vous prêt pour
remporter une majorité sur ce texte
écoutez on sort du Sénat et il me semble
que
après la vie de la Haute Assemblée après
le vote il y a déjà un certain nombre de
compromis et de chemin quand il s'est
trouvé c'est plutôt rassurant parce que
on est à fond Olivier marlex patron des
députés républicains estiment qu'il faut
établir un vrai droit de veto des mers
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à leur
accorder cette ce cet amendement
les sénateurs sont très proches des élus
municipaux et il vous a pas échappé
qu'ils étaient ce que je veux dire c'est
qui vous a pas échappé que certains
d'entre eux étaient entrés dans
l'hémicycle avec l'idée que la bonne
solution c'était un droit de veto puis
vous avez des associations d'élus qui
ont expliqué pourquoi ça leur semblait
être une mauvaise idée je pense que
quand les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale vont entrer dans le détail du
texte et vont échanger avec leurs
collègues du Sénat ils comprendront
pourquoi c'est une fausse bonne idée
donc vous comptez sur un accord entre
député et sénateurs finalement non je
compte sur le fait que la sagesse du
Sénat puisse infuser jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale sur ce sujet sinon tant pis
pour le texte ou vous irez jusqu'au 49-3
non je suis intimement convaincu que les
voix d'un accord existent c'est quand
même un sujet d'intérêt général on va
pas se disputer sur tous les textes dans
ce pays on peut pas tout s'expliquer y
compris lancer des missions d'enquête
pour dire il faut sur les questions
climatiques qu'on soit plus mobilisées
certains dans ce pays sont
malheureusement encore contre le
nucléaire alors que la preuve de son
efficacité climatique existe mais il y a
au moins un sujet qui réunit tout le
monde c'est la nécessité qu'on accélère
sur les énergies renouvelables certains
peuvent avoir des réserves sur tel ou
tel type d’énergie renouvelables mais on
sait que c'est ce qui a de mieux et
qu'on a besoin de produire davantage
d'énergie parce que si demain on veut
pouvoir se passer du pétrole sans pour
autant que chacun réussit soit il faut
bien qu'on soit capable de produire de
l'électricité qui alimentera les
batteries qui permettra pas assez
exploiter justement est-ce que c'est un
quelque chose que vous regardez vous
avez tout à fait raison je pense qu'on a
autour de la géothermie des pistes
extrêmement importantes sur lesquelles
on peut travailler et pour ne rien vous
cacher je suis en ce moment même en
train de regarder comment nous pourrions
équiper le ministère de l'écologie d'un
site de géothermie pour assurer une
partie de sa de sa neutralité donc
mais pourtant c'est pas normal on est en
ce moment même en train de finaliser
l'approche vous savez pas prévu de vous
le dire mais puisque vous m'interrogez
et que vous me prenez au début
notamment parce que je peux parler
alors je vais vous en dire un mot de
plus moi je suis convaincu que la
politique c'est d'abord de l'exemplarité
et donc au moment où vous tenez un
discours sur la nécessité de faire en
sorte d'aller vers des énergies
renouvelables ou de conduire des
opérations de rénovation il faut que les
pouvoirs publics ils commencent par se
l'appliquer à eux-mêmes pour ici
entraîner les citoyens sur un certain
nombre de sujets et donc très
concrètement puisqu'on sait que un des
postes principaux des missions c'est ce
qui fuit c'est ce qui s'échappe de nos
bâtiments c'est on a une nécessité y
compris dans des bâtiments publics avoir
une perspective de rénovation de passage
aux énergies renouvelables de manière
ambitieuse
oui alors que vous avez annoncé pour le
15 décembre l'ouverture en face de test
pour pour l'instant c'est donc pour le
rappeler inscrit dans la loi
anti-gaspillage de 2020 me semble-t-il
pour une économie circulaire qui prendra
la forme d'un forfait de 10 à 45 euros
selon le type d'appareils à réparer oui
j'ai mes notes tous les deux c'est plus
facile super
500 réparateurs ont agréé me semble-t-il
500 pour l'ensemble du territoire est-ce
que c'est pas un petit peu faible au
regard des enjeux pour mi-décembre c'est
très exactement la raison pour la
question c'est une phase de test c'est à
dire que on sait que ce nombre de
réparateurs il est insuffisant par
rapport aux besoins avec des annonces
qui sont arrivées au milieu du mois de
novembre
c'est une forme d'appel pour qu'un
certain nombre de gens puissent penser à
faire la démarche pour se faire gérer
parce que je pense qu'il y a des gens
qui pourraient se faire agréer comme
réparateur et qui n'avait pas forcément
des artisans qui nous disent ils
s'arrête en cours de certification ça
coûte de l'argent c'est un peu lourd
administrativement parce qu'il faut
envoyer les factures à comment ça
s'appelle écho système écosystème voilà
pour se faire rembourser est-ce que vous
entendez ces critiques le choix qui a
été fait par le gouvernement c'est que
ce soit simple pour celui qui fait
réparer son appareil et donc que le prix
soit déduit de la facture évidemment ça
veut dire qu'il y a derrière un peu d'un
jeune arrangement d'ingénierie et de
suivi administratif on est au début du
processus vous l'avez dit il commence
dans un mois moi ce que je veux quand
même dire c'est que voilà un exemple
d'une écologie concrète et positive qui
est bonne pour le pouvoir d'achat qui
est bonne pour l'emploi qui est bonne
pour le climat l'enjeu c'est qui est 2
millions
électroménagers de plus chaque année
qu'on ne jette pas et qu'on répare qu'on
augmente de 20% ce qu'on répare et je
pense qu'on peut aller bien plus loin
c'est encore une fois un enjeu
climatique parce que prélever des
ressources dans la nature pour faire en
sorte de produire des nouveaux objets
les jetés alors qu'ils pourraient être
réparés c'est gaspiller c'est être dans
une forme d'insouciance dont on doit
aussi sortir sur ces sujets et encore
une fois je le redis bon pour le pouvoir
d'achat bon pour l'emploi bon pour le
climat donc on va insister sur ce qui
est positif on va faire en sorte de le
renforcer que ça fait si vous êtes aussi
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
le Congrès des mersouve la semaine
s'ouvre la semaine prochaine et les mers
sont inquiets pour leur pouvoir d'agir
c'est le thème de leur congrès ils sont
inquiets pour leur marge de manœuvre ils
ne veulent pas d'un encadrement de leurs
dépenses soutenues par les
parlementaires le Sénat 10 c'est une
ligne rouge est-ce que vous allez
renoncer à cette mesure vous savez que
nous sommes en train de discuter
notamment avec les sénateurs sur ce
sujet la discussion parlementaire elle
est en cours vous savez moi je suis le
ministre qui
a reçu les associations des lieux au
début du mois de juillet avec Caroline
cailleux avec Gabriel Attal en leur
disant on arrête les contrats de corps
on vous a entendu le contrat de Cahors
c'était vous venez chez le préfet vous
signez devant lui un papier comme quoi
vous allez être vertueux il y a plus
rien à signer parce que la logique c'est
qu'on vous fait confiance le seul sujet
c'est que si on a une trajectoire des
finances publiques qui dérape là on ira
regarder individuellement les situations
et on avait un dispositif dit la station
des mères de France il dit c'est ce sont
les contrats de Cahors en pire
parfois les propos peuvent dépasser la
pensée et donc dans ce domaine il faut à
la fois raison garder quand on regarde
la réalité du texte si vous avez vu dans
le détail à la fois ce qui était proposé
en début de discussion et quelques
tensions qui sont apparues avec les
assurétion de la loi de programmation
des finances publiques on fait du coup
un dispositif qui était prévu dans ce
texte a été réintroduit à l'intérieur du
PLF sous une forme un peu plus rude que
la manière dont nous avions discuté
négocié avec les collectivités locales
on est en train de regarder comment on
atterrit collectivement sur un
dispositif intelligent pour le moment je
le redis il y a une co-construction
législative qui est en train de se faire
avec le cap voici
vous êtes un élu local
qui disent pendant que l'État est
endetté à plus de 120% de de du PIB on
nous réclame on réclame un rigorisme que
l'État ne s'applique pas à lui-même
est-ce que vous comprenez finalement qui
puisse être un petit peu agacé par cette
attitude d'abord je comprends
l'agacement des élus tout court vous
savez quand vous commencez à un mandat
sous le CO que vous retrouvez à gérer
des tensions à gérer une crise sanitaire
à manquer de temps ou d'occasions en
présentiel pour passer du temps avec
votre équipe avec vos collègues on a
énormément de démission qui sont aussi
liées à ce contexte avec parfois une
agressivité qui s'exprime de manière
rapide vous avez un premier sujet
ensuite vous avez le retour de
l'inflation avant même qu'on discute des
mécanismes et de relation qui n'a jamais
été vu une explosion des prix de
l'énergie qui concerne toutes les
collectivités locales en Europe mais qui
même si chez nous des mesures beaucoup
plus fortes ont été prises que dans
d'autres pays impact les budgets créent
des incertitudes entraîne aussi la
nécessité parfois de pas répercuter
totalement la hausse sur les prix de la
cantine parce qu'on veut préserver les
habitants etc qu'est-ce qu'on fait face
à ça d'abord pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans on remet de l'argent dans
le cadre de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement ça faisait 13 ans que
c'est pas arrivé une partie aujourd'hui
de ceux qui donnent les leçons quand ils
étaient en responsabilités ils ont
diminué la DGF
personne aujourd'hui on nous demande de
l'indexer je rappelle que c'est la
droite qui a cessé de la désindexer puis
la gauche qu'il a diminué et aujourd'hui
on fait comme si elle avait toujours été
indexée que c'était la seule année on ne
le faisait pas c'est pas exact c'est la
première année depuis 13 ans on remet de
l'argent et à côté de cet argent on
ajoute près de 4 milliards et demi de
crédit nouveau 2 milliards et demi dans
le cadre de mesure qui permettent
d'accompagner ce qui se passe en termes
d'énergie et 2 milliards de fond vert
pour accélérer sur les sujets de
transition écologique sont issus de
fonds recyclés alors c'est un hommage à
l'écologie d'utiliser ton recycle et
pour en parler mais pour être précis
c'est de l'argent vraiment nouveau pour
un milliard 7 c'est de l'argent nouveau
pour 300 millions c'est le successeur du
fond friche mais qui était censé
s'arrêter au 1er janvier donc ces 2
milliards de crédits nouveaux par
rapport à ce qui était imaginé il y a 6
mois dans le budget et c'est un milliard
7 de plus à périmètre constant que ce
qui existait dans le budget 2022 il y a
des mères qui sont contraintes c'est ce
qu'ils disent d'augmenter la taxe
foncière notamment à Paris Anne Hidalgo
qui va l'augmenter de 50%, il dit
qu'elle est contrainte de le faire parce
que le gouvernement n'a pas assumé ses
respons aussi que c'est pour accélérer
la transformation écologique ça devrait
vous faire plaisir qu'est-ce que vous
répondez
on se focalise beaucoup sur Paris pour
des quantités de raisons mais la mère de
Paris n'est pas responsable quand elle
n'assume pas ses responsabilités tout le
monde sait que pari avait une taxe
foncière très basse parce que c'est une
des villes les plus riches de France qui
est en même temps une ville et un
département elle touche les droits de
mutation qui au cours de ces dernières
années ont particulièrement soutenu le
budget des de des collectivités
parisiennes dans un contexte qui est
compliqué pour tout le monde il y a ceux
qui font des efforts il y a ceux qui
considèrent que au contraire il faut
augmenter les impôts je regrette que la
mère de Paris habille ce choix au lieu
d'assumer en expliquant que c'est de la
faute des autres c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait de la politique si vous dites
à cause de l'état que je le fais qu'elle
assume
vous le dites vous-même je voudrais vous
tout le monde sait que la dette à Paris
a explosé tout le monde sait que il y a
pas d'efforts qui ont été faits c'est
parce qu'elle a des soucis à l'intérieur
de sa majorité et qu'elle n'a pas réussi
à aboutir sur des plans d'accord sur des
économies qu'on se retrouve dans cette
situation mais le gouvernement mais bien
sûr que si on compensation des dépenses
covid comme elle dit 52 % d'augmentation
de la taxe foncière c'est de la faute du
gouvernement écoutez je sais qu'on a le
dollars il y a quand même limite un
sujet qui risque de diviser qui divise
d'ailleurs votre majorité et les élus
c'est la corrida est-ce qu'il faut
l'interdire comme le propose la France
insoumise
d'abord moi je me réjouis que l'attitude
globale de la majorité présidentielle
c'est était de laisser la liberté de
vote parce que vous comprenez que c'est
pas un sujet sur lequel c'est facile
d'avoir une opinion ça peut parfois
interroger l'intime de chacun je déplore
que la France insoumise utilise une
niche parlementaire pour faire une sorte
de coût médiatique pendant deux heures à
discuter d'un sujet dans un contexte où
je pense sincèrement que les Français
ont d'autres préoccupations la position
du gouvernement qui a été rendue
publique ces dernières heures c'est de
dire on veut pas envoyer le signal qu'on
interdit des traditions et avec
accessoirement cette idée que un sujet
comme celui-là mériterait au lieu d'une
proposition cash par un député
médiatique qui veut retrouver une place
dans les médias comprennent le temps
d'avoir une concertation des échanges il
y a peut-être des marges sur lesquels on
peut discuter mais il y a une forme de
provocation qui d'ailleurs je pense est
totalement assumée par la France
insoumise par exemple l'interdiction aux
personnes de moins de 16 ans c'est pour
vous une piste vous savez encore une
fois entre
les différents sujets dont je m'occupe
je peux pas dire que j'ai travaillé dans
le détail la proposition de loi de
Monsieur Caron pour savoir comment elle
pourrait être amendée ce que j'observe
c'est que derrière vous avez des sujets
si j'ai bien compris concerne aussi les
combats de coq en particulier outre-mer
et dans le Nord de la France c'est pour
ça que je prends volontairement cet
exemple avec vous et donc il y a
certaines personnes qui contenu de leurs
habitudes
culturelles ou locales
ne comprennent absolument pas ce que
sont les traditions des autres mais ont
parfois une sorte de bienveillance avec
ce qui se passe près de chez eux et donc
là dessus et il faut se garder d'avoir
des discours qui soit définitifs ou
moralisateur et effectivement regarder
parce que je pense qu'à la fin ça fait
le jeu des extrêmes tout court vous
finissez par agiter des sujets alors
c'est facile parce que ça tient en
quelques minutes sur la manière de les
présenter mais derrière ça veut pas dire
qu'on cherche à construire une nation ça
veut dire qu'on cherche au contraire à
amplifier ces divisions et on a déjà
tellement de sujets sur lequel il faut
qu'on s'efforce d'apaiser quand on est
en situation de responsabilité en plus
plus être ministre vous êtes secrétaire
général d'horizon c'est le parti
d'Édouard Philippe est-ce qu'il y aura
des listes horizons aux élections
sénatoriales il y aura évidemment des
candidats horizons c'est pas ici dans
cette maison que je vais vous rappeler
que les élections sénatoriales répondent
à des logiques particulières qui sont
pas des listes nationales que ce sont
des configurations locales dans certains
départements où il y a beaucoup de
sénateurs on est parfois davantage dans
des optimes de liste mais dans beaucoup
d'autres ce sont des candidatures
individuelles horizon ce sera dans son
lancement quand Edward où se seront des
candidats et des listes ensemble quand
Édouard Philippe a lancé horizon il a
expliqué que un des enjeux pour lui
c'était de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
redonner aux élus locaux une place dans
le débat public que la fin du cumul des
mandats faisait que du coup les mères en
particulier cessaient d'avoir voie au
chapitre sur le sujet national et qu'il
fallait qu'on redonne des espaces
d'expression c'est ce qui se passe avec
le lancement du parti près de 500 mères
aujourd'hui qui nous ont rejoints plus
de 500 comités sur le plan local l'enjeu
c'est évidemment qu'à l'occasion de ces
élections sénatoriales on fasse entendre
la voix de la majorité
présidentielle au sens large on a
quelques marges de progression au sein
de la Haute Assemblée et évidemment la
voie d'horizon à l'intérieur de tout ça
je n'en suis pas là on fait les choses
par étape dernière question sur les
mascotte oui parce que vous êtes étonné
vous avez étonné que que la production
de la mascotte les petites frises là qui
est pour les JO de 2024 soit faite en
Chine
est-ce que vous avez eu l'assurance
depuis que elle serait produite en
France je dois avoir un échange avec le
président du comité d'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques dans la journée donc on
va voir quelques échanges vous allez lui
rappeler quoi que j'étais quand même un
petit un peu important quand même que ça
soit en France moi j'ai l'habitude quand
je conviens d'un rendez-vous
téléphonique avec quelqu'un de pas faire
la conversation téléphonique par avance
sur le plateau en face des journalistes
et d'attendre le moment on va pouvoir
échanger et je vais lui faire part
évidemment de mon émotion dans un
premier temps et du fait que en termes
de symboles ça me semble être un très
mauvais signal au moment où d'autres
compétitions sportives font parler
d'elle sur l'île de dragon merci
à vous d'avoir été notre invité on
revoit la Une de La Voix du Nord c'est
l'eau la fin de l'insouciance merci
merci
à vous